new details are emerging about the
motive for this week's massacre in tulsa
oklahoma and it comes as we've learned
more about the four people that were
gunned down at that tulsa medical office
and tulsa is where we find our nancy
chen covering the story for us this
morning it's a tough story no matter
what nancy but for you i think it's
particularly sensitive because this is
your hometown we're talking about
it is tony it certainly hits very close
to home and police say the gunman did
not choose his target at random they say
that he blamed one of the doctors in
that office for his recent pain after a
back surgery
he came in with the intent to kill dr
phillips
and anyone who got in his way tulsa
police chief wendell franklin says a
letter found on the gunman who killed
four people at a medical building
wednesday and then himself made it clear
he targeted his own surgeon dr preston
phillips he blamed dr phillips
for the ongoing pain
following the surgery the gunman killed
dr phillips a harvard medical school
graduate who regularly volunteered
overseas
dr stephanie houston a sports and
internal medicine specialist
receptionist amanda glynn a mother of
two boys
and clinic visitor william love an army
veteran who police say held a door shut
so others could flee the family of mr
love i'm so sorry we couldn't save you
we are grieving with you
police say the shooter legally purchased
both weapons used in the shooting
including an ar-15 style rifle similar
to these he bought a little more than an
hour before the massacre these folks
deserve better oklahoma deserves better
oklahoma state representative melissa
provenzano's district includes the
medical building she says even though
police took immediate action much more
can be done to prevent similar shootings
what are you calling for we need to take
action ahead of something like this
happening and put 24-hour waiting period
background checks and get rid of the
anti-red flag while these things we
could do now
now saint francis hospital is a hub in
this community and employs more than 10
000 people one of them being my mom now
understandably a lot of them are shaken
up that something like this could happen
in a place of healing but even so they
continue to show up and care for patient
scale
wait nancy i know you said it's close to
home but this is very close to home this
must have been very terrifying for you
when you heard the news and i'm assuming
your mom is okay absolutely
she was she had finished uh her shift
for the day and was at home but you you
see those headlines and those notes come
in i didn't know at the time that she
had just left and uh certainly a very
exhausting and terrifying experience for
so many here
it's so frightening i feel we're all
human lotteries just walking around it
could happen at any time hoping before
you come back to new york you stop by
and say hey to your mom nancy thank you
thank you very much